America is the freest country in the
world just ask anyone who's never been
outside of the country but it wasn't
always this way what if I told you that
the US used to make all kinds of wacky
things illegal the great con man Harold
Hill once convinced a town to allow a
boy's Brass Band so kids didn't fall
victim to dangerous crimes like gambling
smoking or reading ballzack
Ballack but what else did America once
ban now Americans have always been
suspicious of dancing and we have the
Puritans to thank for way back in 1684
an OG Boston scold named increase ma
published an anti dancing pamphlet
called an arrow against profane and
promiscuous dancing which argues that
dancing quote drowns out the quiver of
the scriptures thankfully Americans
excel at finding ways to get around
impressive laws in the 1830s people
organized play parties no not that kind
of play Party where they played
children's games allowing them to chant
and clap as a way to avoid bands on
dancing and these parties persisted
until the 1950s laws Banning dancing
almost always started at the city level
uh C Elmore City Oklahoma which made
dancing strictly illegal in 1898 that
law stood for almost 90 years until a
group of high school students wanted to
overturn the band and have a real senior
problem with dancing the students faced
opposition from the city's religious
leaders like this guy uh they beat of
Music the curves of the body the display
of the outward person we don't believe
it's congruent with the principles of
Bible Doctrine especially but the
students held bake sales and fundraisers
for their prom they taught each other to
dance and eventually the city council
repealed the law by a margin of three
votes to two Lisa Rawlings was a
sophomore in Elmore City High at the
time her dad the mayor helped change the
rule she says a new boy in town pictured
here got the ball rolling so I think
Leonard's probably the one who who asked
the question just because he was an
outer towerer now Leonard's real name
was not Kevin Bacon but when people
magazine covered Elmore City's prom it
got the attention of screenwriter Dean
Pitchford who went on to write the
screenplay for foot loose today Elmore
City hosts an annual Foot Loose Festival
where as you can imagine everyone Cuts
Foot Loose now even after Foot Loose
small town dancing bands still stuck
around in many parts of the country the
Supreme Court held that social dancing
is generally not covered by the First
Amendment whereas partially new dancing
is expressive enough to be worthy of
first amendment protection that gave
towns cover to regulate social dances
and so dancing was effectively banned in
places like pound Virginia until well
into the 21st century now pound's anti-d
dancing ordinance banned dancing in any
place open to the public that did not
first obtain a dance hall permit from
the city council the council was not
allowed to issue a permit quote to a
person who is not a person of good moral
character and the council was also
required to consider the proximity of a
proposed dance hall to residential areas
churches or schools and you can probably
guess what the Cutaway is going to be
right here won't somebody please think
of the children well obviously someone
did think of the children because the
prohibition on Dancing had a chilling
effect on its citizens desires to do the
twist no no one even tried to apply for
a permit until William Elam the owner of
the golden Pine restaurant applied for a
permit to host country line dancing but
Elam withdrew the petition after 200
Pitchfork wielding towns people showed
up at a city council meeting to oppose
the application but Elam sued the city
and won the town argued that it had a
legitimate State interest in stopping
people from drinking too much the court
agreed that this was a legitimate
concern the ordinance was so broad that
it applied even to places where alcohol
wasn't consumed for example a for-profit
performance of The Nutcracker ballot
would require prior approval from the
Town Council even if it were performed
in a place that did not commonly serve
or sell alcohol the Court ruled that the
terms dancing moral character and proper
person were unconstitutionally vague and
over Brad because the Pound Town Council
yeah this the Pound Town Council uh had
the sole discretion to Bar public
performances of dances social or
otherwise quote merely by declaring that
the sponsor of such a dance was an
improper person or one who lacked good
moral character and despite this ring
the city was undaunted by the setback
and enacted a new dancing ban Elam
continued hosting dirty dances at his
club and state authorities revoked the
golden Pine restaurants licensed to sell
alcohol and although the golden Pine
eventually closed the police department
didn't last much longer than the
restaurant it was disbanded in 2021
because its officers mishandled so much
evidence that prosecutors had to drop 31
criminal cases in fact the town spent so
much time and money stopping its
citizens from doing the Tango that had
forgot how to be an actual town in 2022
the Virginia legislature revoked the
town Charter after repeated failures to
do basic things like pass a budget or
maintain a Wastewater Plant but if you
thought that this stopped lawmakers in
Western Virginia from regulating dancing
well think again Wise County stepped up
to make sure that the citizens of pound
and other citizens in the county did not
fall prey to the vicissitudes of the
chaa or the waltz today Wise County
regulates public dance halls and the
cops have the right to enter at any time
to make sure that patrons are quote
conducting themselves in a Peaceable and
orderly fashion wise County's anti-d
dancing ordinance repeats the same quote
proper person language that the federal
court found to be problematic but on the
upside we'll probably get a sequel to
Foot Loose sometime soon now dancing
kind of makes sense when you think about
it but did you know that pinball is
considered the devil's balls well when
the Supreme Court struck down a federal
ban on sports betting in 2018 states
were eager to legalize gambling 36
States and the District of Columbia now
allow you to lose your shirt betting on
the ponies or you know the commanders as
the case may be but America was not
always so bullish on gambling in the
1920s moral scolds targeted coin
operated gambling machines like pinball
now no one loved to demonize pinball
more than New York mayor fiorella
LaGuardia the man whose name is now
emblazoned on one of America's worst
airports wasn't shy about preaching
pinballs links to juvenile delinquency
and World War II gave him a new talking
point pinball was anti-American and
after the Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor
uh mayor LaGuardia said it was
infinitely preferable that the metal in
these evil Contraptions be manufactured
into arms and bullets which can be used
to destroy our foreign enemies and he
banned pinball and New York City Police
conducted raids on the city's candy
shops and amusement parks now mayors in
Washington DC New Orleans Milwaukee and
Chicago followed theia's lead in
campaign photographs of the era show
lawmakers and lawmen posing with the
Hammers they used to smash up pinball
machines here's a newsreel showing the
police proudly removing these dangerous
objects after they were outlawed New
York City completes a Roundup of
thousands of pinball machines each
valued at about $100
no more of this in Manhattan and the
politics of pinball lasted well into the
1960s Republicans thought they had JFK's
number when they found a photo of him
standing next to a man who was a silent
partner in an Indiana pinball joint
later Kennedy's brother Bobby waged war
on Interstate pinball gambling and to
bring It full circle attorney Jim
Garrison who tried to solve JFK's
assassination was indicted in 1971 for
accepting bribes from a mafia Kingpin
who wanted him to protect pinball
gambling and you thought you lived in
the dumbest timeline but of course the
demonization of pinball made the game
cool and that's why so many movies and
TV shows set in the 50s and 60s show
their leather jacket wearing Rebels
playing pinball but California finally
put an end to this pinball Madness when
the state supreme court found that
pinball was a game of skill in
1974 when the Los Angeles banned pinball
in 1938 pinball players didn't have many
ways to impact their score other than by
jostling the machine to manipulate the
ball but in 1947 flippers were invented
giving players more control over what
happened to the ball after it was
launched and a group of business owners
sued la alleging that the addition of
flippers changed pinball into a game of
skill that couldn't be regulated by the
city the trial court agreed and the
California Supreme Court affirmed
holding that the city's law was
preempted by state regulation of games
of skill the court also suggested that
treating games of chance differently
than games of skill could violate the
equal protection Clause but the anti-
pinball Crusaders have not completely
disappeared though in South Carolina you
can walk down any Street openly carrying
a handgun but it's still illegal for
miners to play Pinball and the
legislature is now in 2023 gearing up
for a big debate on whether to repeal
the pinball ban uh gosh really tackling
the the most important uh and
potentially dangerous issues there in
that election cycle now if you're ever
arrested for playing pinball you'll
probably need a good lawyer because the
local sheriff probably has it out for
you but if you want a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can help if you've
suffered an injury or death in the
family gotten in car crash or dealing
with workers comp or Social Security
issues we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney who can it's so
important to talk to Ayer right away so
you can get the best represent ation and
find out what your options are so just
click on the link in the description for
free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team the link is down
below now one of Johnny Carson's most
popular bits was the great carac sis
boomba sis
[Music]
boomba describe the sound made when a
sheep explodes but fortune telling is
not always a laughing matter the Supreme
Court has said that quote the First
Amendment does not Shield fraud and in
the old days fortune telling was
regarded as an inherently fraudulent
occupation that was so deceptive that it
could not qualify as free speech the
fortune tellers probably should have
seen that one coming and there are
dozens of court cases confirming this
view for example in 1928 the city of
Cleveland charged gerre Davis with
having violated section 13145 of the
general code prohibiting and penalizing
fortune telling the state law barred
fortune telling without a license but
neither the city or the state actually
provided a way for anyone to get that
license and the Ohio Supreme Court did
not care about this particular Catch 22
surmising that the words licensing were
just surplusage that could be read out
of the statute Davis argued that fortune
telling was a legitimate business that
wasn't penalized at common law but as
the court explained the opposite was
true in the UK palmistry astrology and
fortune telling were crimes and the same
was true in the Canadian and American
colonies people who practiced occult
trades were not allowed to run
legitimate businesses despite the fact
that kings and queens and Nancy Reagan
consulted astrologists and fortune
tellers for advice honestly they
probably should have seen that one
coming too are there any psychics in
this
town but the Ohio court rejected Davis's
free speech claim on grounds that the
state had the power to regulate speech
for the protection of the public health
safety welfare and morals uh these are
known as the state's police powers and
although Davis argued that the law
infringed on her freedom of religion the
court disagreed comparing fortune
telling to polygamy however for decades
fortune tellers have argued that they
really are engaged in legitimate
business activity protected by the due
process clause and they say the tales
that they tell are protected by the
First Amendment and modern courts have
started to legitimize fortune telling as
a profession for example in 2010
Maryland Court struck down Montgomery
County's ban on fortune telling there
Nick nef fedro wanted to open a fortune
telling business in Bethesda but his
father and grandfather always warned him
that Montgomery County was hostile to
Romani people so nef fedro sued the
county the Maryland court of appeals
originally suggested that the county set
up a licensing system quote whereby a
psychic would have to accurately predict
say six out of 10 events in order to
obtain a proper permit but eventually
Maryland's top Court ruled that the
ordinance violated nedra's
constitutional right to freedom of
speech quote we see nothing in the
record to suggest that fortune telling
always involves fraudulent statements
indeed fortune tellers like magicians or
horoscope writers are able to provide
entertainment to their customers or some
other benefit that does not deceive
those who receive their speech the cards
can reveal things that you will never
see by yourself and the Maryland Court
rejected the County's assertion that the
ordinance regulated conduct not speech
as for the county argument that the law
protected people from fraud the court
said quote well we recognize that some
fortune tellers may make fraudulent
statements just as some lawyers or
journalists may we see nothing on the
record to suggest that fortune telling
always involves fraudulent statements
I'm not exactly sure how I feel about
the court analogizing lawyering to
fortune telling but I guess when lawyers
like Sydney El crino Powell have become
household names then the court might
have a point but now that fortune
telling is legal finally America's Rich
lonely people will have someone to talk
to states can still use anti- fraud laws
when a fortune teller crosses the line
when does a fortune teller cross the
line when they commit Larsen and fraud
in the course of a psychic reading
believe it or not not all fortune
telling is automatically considered
abject fraud for example in 2018 the
NYPD arrested psychic Zoey on suspicion
of defrauding clients out of over
$800,000 she allegedly lured one victim
in with a $5 reading and then convinced
her that quote she'd never find love
again unless she bought the psychic a
9.2 karat diamond ring the same victim
gave Zoe over $700,000 for spells and
protections against demons but look you
can't argue with results she hasn't been
attacked by a single demon since she's
gotten those protections now psychic Zoe
pleaded guilty to a scheme to defron and
was sentenced to probation and
restitution I guess she didn't see that
one
[Music]
coming uh yeah it used to be illegal to
sell or buy alcohol on Election Day now
you might think that these laws were
passed during prohibition but they're
actually rooted in a very different time
period from America's earliest days
alcohol was synonymous with voting I
can't vote without it but the first
Democratic body in the American colonies
was the Virginia House of the Burgesses
and many of America's Future Leaders
served in the House of Burgesses
including George Washington Thomas
Jefferson Patrick Henry and George Mason
and at the time only white male land
owners were allowed to vote and they
would line up at Williamsburg and state
their preferences via voce but it was
customary for candidates to ply their
voters with liquor during these events
and in fact young George Washington
tried to win a seat in the house when he
was 24 but he was rebuffed after he
decided against treating voters to booze
3 years later Washington ran again but
this time he showed up with 144 gallons
of alcoholic drinks
let's let's do this now unsurprisingly
the land owners came through for
Washington in a landslide Washington
gave away half a gallon of liquor or
wine for every vote that he won that's
391 votes to be precise and Washington
never forgot the power of booze and
according to popular myth at the Battle
of Trenton he caught the hessin off
guard because they were so wasted well
wait we need to fight but we're kind of
drunk and we're kind of up and
Washington eventually spent 7% of his
White House Budget on spirits and this
wasn't particularly uncommon in the 18th
and 19th centuries politicians realized
that since many saloons were also
polling places they could win votes by
throwing raging keggers when the
landowning men arrived in town and
getting voters SAU became a key strategy
for getting out the vote on Election Day
it was known as quote swilling the
Planters with Bumbo which was a type of
rum and you have to admit half a gallon
of rum sounds better than 50 emails
pleading with you to vote and in the
early 19th century alcohol production
went way up in consumption followed suit
this also meant that regular Joe's and
Janes could get their drink on and that
made America's Elites sort of nervous
and by the mid- 19th century more people
could drink and more people could vote
often at the same time and drinking on
Election Day occasionally led to
violence like the famous incident in
1882 when three McCoys stabbed Ellison
Hatfield 26 times and then shot him to
death I guess they were really bad
stabbing but will Willam devil ants
Hatfield organized a posi and caught up
to the McCoy on their way to the pike
field jail where he kidnapped them tied
them to some POA bushes and shot them
dead and this all fed into the
temperance movement which eventually led
to Prohibition but when prohibition was
repealed States continued to regulate
the most serious problems created by
alcohol and this is how we got age
requirements Sunday bar closings and
title regulations on when and where
alcohol was sold the biggest perceived
problem with alcohol on Election Day was
that it led to public drunkenness and
bribery of Voters and as a decades for
the state to finally repeal the election
day drinking laws with South Carolina
once again coming in last the state
didn't repeal its ban until 2014 however
candidates still can't promise
individual voters liquor in exchange for
votes because that's just common sense
for example in 2013 Arkansas State
Democrat Hudson hollum pleaded guilty to
election fraud after he and several
other men identified absentee voters
contacted voters directly with offers
and then collected the ballots halum
admitted that he bought the votes with
things like chicken dinners and alcohol
and according to the doj halam told his
associate quote we need to use that
black limo and buy a couple of cases of
some cheap vodka and whiskey to get
people to vote two days later Ham's
crony's quote spoke with an individual
in Memphis Tennessee about getting a
discounted price for the purchase of 100
half pints of vodka for the campaign now
halum won his special election with 394
votes strikingly similar to the 391
votes that Washington got back in 1758
but whereas George became America's
first president halam got three years of
Probation and 9 months of home conf
refinement fortunately this
long-standing American tradition is
still respected and embraced in our
nation's fraternities of course if
you're going to get trash to vote this
year you should really sober up with a
delicious home-cooked meal which you can
do with today's sponsor hellofresh so
let's say you decided to actually sit
down and eat dinner around the table
this year but what about those nights
when your schedule is absolutely packed
well you can turn to helloof Fresh's
lineup of quick and easy meals including
their 15-minute recipes designed to help
minimize Meal Time stress it's even
quicker than delivery you never have to
worry about what's for dinner again
because hellofresh is offering their
biggest menu yet with over 45 recipes to
choose from every week each hellofresh
box is packed with farm fresh
ingredients and everything arrives pre-
proportioned right to your doorstep for
less hassle and less wasted food it's a
great way to eat delicious fresh food
while still being healthy now I'm a do-
it-yourself person I have to say I was
initially pretty skeptical about
hellofresh I'm a pretty good cook so I
didn't think that I needed the help but
I actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that I'd never
try on my own and of course everything
was delivered straight to my door so I
didn't have to do any shopping the
produce actually gets to you faster than
a grocery store so it arrives at Peak
freshness and flavor and it's also super
easy to save time hellofresh cuts out
the meal planning and prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes to
cook or even less literally less time to
cook than it would normally take to do
the shopping and hellofresh is at least
25% cheaper than takeout and this is new
because they say that breakfast is the
most important meal of the day and
hellofresh agrees in fact they're giving
all subscribers free breakfast for life
that means that you'll enjoy a totally
free breakfast item with every single
hellofresh delivery so click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description or go to hellofresh.com
and use the code legal eagle free for a
free breakfast item for life that's one
breakfast item free per box while the
subscription is active again just click
on the link below and use the code legal
eagle free at check out for a free
breakfast item for life after that click
on this link over here for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court